la reprise des rotations pour la moitié
de la flotte devenait tropicale rendu
possible après d'ultimes échanges entre
direction et syndicats ce matin près des
bureaux et des ateliers
et puis les premiers bateaux qui partent
pour le ravitaillement à la base
multimodal les nouveaux horaires sont
affichés et les premiers clients
arrivent c'est exceptionnel parce que
même mon client comme il a une maison à
fort de france
et là il a aux trois ilets obligés
d'aller travailler
voilà et je vais voir comment ça se
passe aujourd'hui
et puis le bateau qui rallie la pointe
du bout arrive très peu de passagers à
bord tous étaient rassurés en tout cas
pas de quoi avoir peur
[Musique]
c'est très bien organisé dans le trajet
retour vers la pointe du bout aucun
passager normal le trafic vient à peine
de reprendre aux trois ilets l'équipage
explique certains changements effectués
à bord
[Musique]
non
à chaque fois on a installé des vents de
face à ce que jadis tentation qui se
passe pour les gens et puis dès le
départ le duc et c'est à dire ici sont
vraiment sélectionné à pour la distance
conséquence le nombre de passagers est
divisé par deux sur une flotte de huit
bateaux réduite elle de moitié pour
cette reprise
ce passage est habituée de la ligne lui
est content c'est très rassurant pour
les clients puisque dès l'entrée on vous
propose du gel hydroalcoolique
ensuite on peut directement pointée sur
un serveur hagard donc montré très
rassurant
ah oui absolument deux je prenais la
navette toute l'année puisque je
travaille fort de france
donc c'est pour moi c'est un moyen de
transport essentiel dans ma dans ma vie
tout simplement
pour cette compagnie qui embauche une
quarantaine de salariés reprise ne veut
pas dire être sorti d'affaires il faudra
encore quelques semaines pour sortir
complètement la tête de l'eau